hey everybody its Jesse and today we're
gonna do something a little bit
different so yesterday we worked on just
some styling things and I haven't had a
chance yet to do anything else
with the styles since yesterday
afternoon so I don't have any updates
when it comes to that what I did do
though is I have a server completely up
and running and I have a version of the
resource center project that we've been
working on now live and so what I
thought we could do today is I want to
go through check it out in a browser
first I'm just gonna click around you
know in Chrome and see see what happens
we'll resize the screen maybe open up a
few other browsers and you all will be
able to go through the site with you
know whatever setup that you have I know
I'm on a Mac right now and there's
certainly going to be some of you on
Windows and I know a few of you are on
on Linux systems so in the past we've
had you know very different experiences
depending on our combination of
operating system you know browser or
device so I thought it'd be nice to just
go through and try to figure out you
know if anything just looks really weird
or is you know kind of acting
differently than it should and see if we
can we can fix that you know at the very
least you know it'd be nice to just get
a list of things that that need to be
the need to be fixed so I will say this
the forms are not working right now so I
already know that so if you try to
submit something through the forms
they're not working and I've left the
error message up here basically what's
happening is it's trying
it's trying to send the form data to
http and then our C Francisquito
University and then port 9000 slash
uploads so obviously this is a
ridiculous URL this is not where you
want to send it so I'm gonna work on
that the problems in the service dog a.s
are yeah the service center
I'm sorry service requests today s is
the component where the issues had so
I've done a few things already to try to
correct it obviously it hasn't worked
it's a little tricky because I have to
make the changes push them to get out
pull it down to the server rebuild it
and then test it again so it's not the
the fastest way to do things so I think
I'm just going to think about this for a
little bit instead of changing little
things and trying again and again and
again since the you know the feedback
loop is you're not quite as tight as it
normally is when we're developing
locally okay so let me just let me say
hide everyone to check the live chat
really quick I do have one question
Saran Saran CH says what's this soft on
the screen though you mean what what
software is on the screen I'm not
exactly sure I understand the question
this is just chrome dev tools right now
and I'm running the dark theme so it's
not it looks different than the default
so let's go over let me bring over the
the actual site you can see there's some
things like this page the letterhead
page obviously I haven't finished this
yet so I need I just need to put in the
data for this
so not really a big deal I just keep
forgetting to do that I do want to show
so you can see this this page is exactly
you know how we left it off we already
spent a bunch of time on this page
earlier so I'm not even really gonna
test this out there's not much I mean I
guess we can we can check this out and
see how it looks on a smaller screen and
you know that's that's fine that's what
it's kind of nice about using some sort
of CSS framework especially for a grid
system is that it's normally very
consistent you you don't you don't see
as many bugs like if you try to do your
own you know from scratch it's been my
experience at least that it um if
there's it's way more likely that
there's gonna be some bugs if I try to
do it completely on my own but if I
bring in at least some elements from an
existing system that's used by a lot of
people and it has been tested it's you
know you can reasonably expect that it's
gonna act how you how you want it to act
I do want to check this out because we
haven't we haven't really done much with
this since we've set it up I don't even
remember the last time I looked at this
page so it looks like you know we see we
see all the logos that's fine
this is working that's great
[Music]
getting a phone call but that is some
type of solicitor some representative
from some company keeps trying to get me
to have a meeting and they call me every
day and send me emails I can't even
remember what their company does but for
some reason people think I have
decision-making abilities and the
ability to buy things and I really don't
I mean I just I build the websites I can
make recommendations to people higher up
but oh so let's check that out
not not really a browser specific thing
but don't want that color there in the
drop-down so
let's check that out now so I figure on
normally if I was going to do testing I
would just when I saw something I would
just write it down I put it my Trello
board and then go back to it but that's
gonna be I think somewhat boring to do
so what I'm gonna do now is if I see
something I figured like let's just
we'll dive right in
we'll try to figure out what's going on
and fix it so we may not get through
everything you know in terms of testing
but I think it'll make for a much better
stream in terms of viewing experience
much better than just watching me click
around on the site so let's check out
let's see this is I'm assuming that we
just use the the select input from did
we do so selected we do a drop-down
let's just check out this this page and
see what we use because I'm guessing
there's probably some prop we can pass
in that will change this color if that's
the case then that'll be really easy if
that's not the case this may actually be
a color right now let me check this out
I just said I had an idea we have a
custom theme somewhere I don't think I
have it up already
see there you go it's in the components
holder so we have this custom theme and
I'm so I'm guessing that that's this
pink color here and see we are using it
as an accent color so let's get rid of
that color and let's put in as the
accent color that let's put in that
yellow that we've been using elsewhere
and as I mentioned yesterday if we're
using sass it's better to do variables I
haven't really taken the time to set up
my color variables and things and import
them correctly so this is one of those
cases where it's like yes this works but
this is definitely not the best way to
do it in terms of organization this
could be a lot better but for now let's
switch out this pink I think that's the
only color that really needs you know
everything else is somewhat neutral
right we have different Gray's black
white I'm okay with that
but obviously that pink is not it's not
in the color palette for to the
University so that should work and then
now we don't need this pink so we could
take that out as well and now let's see
what we have here hmm do a hard refresh
hmm has it changed
maybe it's somewhere else oh I don't
know what I was thinking obviously it
wouldn't change it we're checking the I
was checking on the live version so let
me click whoops I didn't put this in in
quotes so so this is the local version
so we should see the changes reflected
immediately here so let's check it out
all right great so now we have that
color I'm not a hundred percent sure
this is the color I want here but at
least it's a color that's on the
official color palette for the
University so it'll be all right it does
match you know what we have here so I'm
okay with that for right now let's keep
going and I do want to check the I want
to do the checks on the live version
alright let's see yeah those links look
good
so our logos page is good on our posters
page so on this page we had the same
issue that we have the home page in that
you know we have a few cards here and we
have it vertically aligned to be in the
center yesterday when we worked on it on
the home page you know we we tried it
out being not vertically centered and it
was you know obviously it looked better
so I think we should probably do that
here as well there's enough content here
and a little bit of color with these
links I don't think we need to add that
that little kind of bar with the accent
color that we did on the home page let
me know what you all think though
because you know we might want to do
that
I don't know I don't I guess I could see
going both ways we could have
consistency by doing it or you know it
could be overdoing it if we use it for
everything but for now at least I do
want to move this up so that instead of
being vertically centered it's just at
the top all the time so let's do that
now
pages this posters and I forgot to set
my timer oops
of it on the other page let's set my
timer and that would be a good time to
explain what's going on for anybody
that's that's new to hey everybody and
EMS are you using web Pappa web pack I
am using webpack but I'm using create
react apps so they took care of all the
web pack config so I don't I haven't
done anything with the config to
customize it but behind the scenes web
pack is doing a lot of stuff
all right so for anybody that's that's
new if you haven't seen any Austrians
before this is me doing my everyday work
so it's not not really a tutorial
although I try to explain things as best
I can so some of the work gets done in
between streams and I try to catch
everybody up on what I've done the way I
break up the stream is that I use a
Pomodoro timer so it's a 25-minute
session of coding or whatever we happen
to be working on and then five minutes I
go back to the live chat and I answer
any questions that anybody's posted in
the live chat then we do another
25-minute session I like to do at least
two sessions per stream sometimes more
today I think I'm gonna keep it a
shorter stream because I I'm still just
not feeling well I have a sore throat I
don't want to lose my voice and I really
have a lot of work that I need to get to
I want to get that service request form
working but I'm also I have that if
you've been watching you know that I
have that Udacity react nano degree that
I'm working on and there's a project due
soon I need to double-check but I'm
pretty sure I have until September 15th
if anybody's in that course and I have
the the date wrong let me know although
it depends on when you signed up I guess
but I need the project the project needs
done so I really need to get to work on
that as well but in any case we get in
to Pomodoro sessions and then at the end
whenever I'm done with the coding I
answer any questions there in the live
chat I almost always get a chance to
answer every question occasionally for
if there's something like a meeting I
have and I really have to cut it short I
won't get to them all but I would say
you know 99% of the time I get to all
the questions so if I don't get to your
question right away if you can stick
around till the end I will answer it all
right so let's start this up we'll go in
here to the posters jazz component and
you can see all this code on github
so there's a link in the description
we're on the master branch right now so
you've if you want to follow along or
see how the how the code works you can
go there feel free to clone the project
if you want to use it if you just want
to mess around with it or use some of it
as a base as a basis for your own
project or if you'd like to submit a
pull request to this project that's
that's awesome you know feel free to use
any of it I mean obviously you can't use
the University logo I don't have
permission to let's use that as well but
all the code you can certainly use
however you want to use it okay posters
thanks I think we can get rid of this so
we did have a logos posters view and I
think we can get rid of this because
we're not gonna use that now we set
things up differently so let's just
delete that while we're in here and we
already have enough going on with all
our file structure we don't need to keep
in things that aren't doing anything
right now okay so in our posters this
should be a really easy fix
let's find our container here we go if
we remove this class of the line wrapper
right this is the class that's giving us
our vertical alignment and we've
imported this you know we brought it
over from materialized CSS so we're not
using the entire framework mainly
because it's a lot of it is based on
jQuery I don't want to use jQuery with
react for various reasons that we've
gone over and previous streams if you
really want to know the reasons ask me
in the live chat and I'll explain it on
one of the breaks but there are some
really helpful things in materialized
that we brought over so the grid system
they're responsive font sizes and also
this vertical align alignment class that
uses flex behind the scenes there so if
we take that out that should fix our
alignment let's I keep forgetting that
we're no I guess I shouldn't have
removed that so I deleted that file but
I must be using it somewhere let's see
where
what is going on
I need to figure out why let me try
restarting the server before I go in and
start doing anything else
see if we get the same error or not
I think we are yep we are okay so it
looks like it's a little bit here we go
routes that's what I wanted to say I
thought it was in routes but better to
just kind of wait and see what line is
that does it say alright it's not
telling me a line but let's check out
our he said routes component let me
there we go raus and let's remove that
[Applause]
from logos posters let's get rid of that
and see if we have it anywhere else
them as posters yeah we don't need that
here either okay so that should work now
great all right so let's check out that
posters page see there you go now we
don't have that vertical alignment so I
am going to check in the lab check
because I asked about the the styles for
this I'm gonna see if anyone has any
opinions on that also I forgot to
mention to anyone watching on Instagram
if you want to see the code that I'm
working on right now that you can you
can kind of see the edge of the screen
there a little bit but if you want to be
able to get a better view of the code
check out the free code camp YouTube
channel I'm live right now if you see
the recording of this then the recording
will be available the title of this
stream or this this video is browser
testing react projects and I should have
I should have put browser testing a
react project I guess it doesn't really
matter I just it's hard for me to come
up with titles sometimes but anyway
it'll be browser testing and that's
project 2 day 31 of live coding with
Jesse so if you're watching on free code
camp right now then in the end you want
to see see me while I code you can check
out the Instagram the links in the
description for the video so it looks
like John Hanson says consistency of
design is always good yeah yeah we
definitely could let me see how this
looks again
here's what I'm I'm kind of torn though
because on the home page these are all
really links I mean it's not like the on
the interior pages these are more
informational blocks of text so they do
have a different function I mean some of
these are lengths but functionally these
cards are different so I think we have a
reason to treat them differently I'm you
know I think it works with these cards
they're very small
I just am worried that it'll be too much
on these larger cards I'm gonna think
about it we'll go on and check out some
of the other pages I'm gonna think about
it if you all have any opinions on
whether or not we should put a colored
border on the left of these cards let me
know in the live chat please but I see
video tutorials oh yeah let's not forget
this page so this page has tutorial
videos yeah I think this is fine there's
not really much to do on this page just
needs to display the videos one thing I
think I do want to do to keep things
consistent is have a title on every page
right now only some of the pages have
the title so I think it would be nice to
have the title here for each page or at
least something here for each page so
let me go back and see I'm okay with not
having it here for logos because we have
this this menu here so I don't really
want to add another thing here
yeah so we should put I should put
letterhead here as a title at the top
yeah let's do that now let me see how I
did this in posters okay I just had it
had a div that's h2 and Pedro says
letterhead
so it might be a bit too small to see
but over here in our all our folders
here all each page is its own component
in the views folder so you have them
separated out from the rest of the
components and there pretty much all of
them are named the same name as the
title of that page we also have all of
our tests that we're running for the
pages there with within the views folder
as well
okay so let's throw in let's try to put
that in right here and see what it looks
like
letterhead I don't think we need this
flex here I think that was necessary
when we were doing the vertical
alignment I don't think it is anymore
we'll find out
okay so we have letterhead what's
different we have a different class
going on here flow text okay so let's
let's add the flow text class here
and this is that responsive font font
size class that I was talking about a
few minutes ago that we brought in from
materialized so all this does is it
changes the font size based on screen
width so if you add that here we're
gonna end up with there we go so end up
with a larger header a larger heading
and then we also have larger text here I
don't know that I like how much space is
there let's see yeah we definitely don't
have nearly as much space here so let's
get rid of some of the space
let's see where that's coming from
so I guess this Pete yeah I think if we
just get rid of the margin that should
be good yeah that looks a lot better
that's more reasonable
we could probably shorten that gap even
more but I think that's I think that
looks all right so let's do that in this
case I like to put a style like this
directly on this age tag if I find on
some other pages I need to do something
similar then I may think about just kind
of globally doing this but I'd rather
not put a style directly I'd rather not
set a global style for an age tag like
that because we may use this in other
places and so I just don't want to
inadvertently mess up Styles elsewhere
but in react we can use styles in line
let me do it a little bit differently
than you normally would in HTML so we
have our Styles you know like normal or
styles property but then we put these
curly brackets the first set of brackets
means that we're gonna do some
JavaScript inside of here the second set
just makes an object right like normally
if we're doing JavaScript brackets or an
object right and then we can write
let's see Louie De Marchi and bottom
there so we can do margin-bottom camel
cased not hyphenated like we normally do
in CSS so you do that camel case just
like a normal object we're going to put
our colon and then we're gonna put our
value I'm gonna put 0 pixels here I
think it would work
let's just try it out just for a
demonstration here since it's just a
numerical value if I put the zero it
should work even if it's not in in
quotation marks maybe it didn't work
all right let's try this again so this
was good I thought it would work
although I'd never tried it so let's try
this again let's try it like this
hmm did it not work either way I could
be that
hmm
oops I put an S there I'm sure you all
caught that sorry about that okay so
that worked here now now I'm really
curious I do actually want to see if
this works with just us here okay and in
fact it does work right so normally when
you do styles like this you have to put
that bat value as a string right you
have to put it in in quotes or the back
take if you're gonna do a template
literal something like that but if the
value is just numerical then you can put
that in and it works as well okay great
so this is looking better as I said I
think this is the first page I had up on
the screen when we first started
checking there's a lot more than he's
done on this page and if we get through
everything else we may come back to this
and just start start changing some
things on here but for now I'm gonna
move on because what I'm looking for
mostly right now is you know kind of
really obvious things that need change
you know padding things things like that
I really actually I really don't like
how this card title is up here without
any padding but we're not gonna use the
card title so I'm not gonna worry about
it right now I just have to keep that in
mind later on if we if we do end up
using a card with this this title here
okay let's check out our share story
page okay that looks good we don't have
a title here so let's put that in I
think I'll just call it
hmm sorry is yawning yeah let's put in a
heading but just says shared story I
wanna I can't remember what I call it on
the homepage suggest the story yeah
maybe I'll put suggestive story since
that's how I have it here okay so let's
just bring in let's copy what we have
here and we'll put that in story so
we're in the story j/s component right
now and we have more more than usual
going on in this component since we have
a form here and we have to handle that
form data but for this we don't need to
change mas it's just a story
all right let's check it out whoops and
let's move this flow text up to the
container div
there we go
all right and I want to shrink this down
just to see how this looks okay
no bad I'm kind of I don't really know
what I can do about it right now but I
mean let's think if this was really
somebody's fun they're only gonna see
this at first I think I have to scroll
down before they get to the forum I can
see that as being somewhat annoying
especially if someone has already gone
through all this you know several times
it's not a long scroll I don't know that
it would really look right though if I
just had the form first and then the
explanation under that so I guess it'll
have to be like this for now to be
honest though very few people access the
current version of this right now on
their phones and this suggests a story
form is rarely used I mean where I would
be surprised if it's been used more than
a dozen times in the last year so
probably shouldn't put too much thought
into this right now
because it it really won't be seen by
that many people and it'll be used by
even you know fewer people
all right let's share the service
request form now we do have some stuff
going on here that we need to think
about you know fixing I haven't looked
at it on a more narrow screen yet okay
not bad so you can see right away
there's some some things going on with
spacing here like are are checkboxes
that have icons have a ton of space
between them we need to fix that and
make it consistent with the rest of the
checkboxes I don't love the fact that
this goes down onto another line but it
actually lines up with this button
somewhat so I'm not
I'm not really that worried about it hmm
this completion date line doesn't go all
the way to the end although we certainly
don't need that space for a date it
would look more consistent if this went
full width so maybe it will do that all
right so right away we need to work on
these check boxes you know possibly we
need to make this a bit bigger you know
full width and we do have some issues
where okay so on the when these are full
with this works but look what happens
whenever we go up like this all right so
you see it messes up a lot of what's
going on here so let me let me go back
out here right so our project
description is here in this side but if
I put the wrong value in there the
project description actually even flips
to the other side now so at first I
didn't notice this it was earlier today
that I first noticed is that not only do
we have more space here but it's
actually flipping the order around so we
definitely want to figure out what's
going on here and fix that so that it
doesn't change the order that's probably
the checkbox spacing in this are gonna
be the number one number one and two
priorities on this page let me go back I
did ask a few questions about you know
your opinions actually I have three
minutes yeah I'll just work on this for
a little bit and then on the 5-minute
break I'll go back and check out what
you all thought about the few things
that I'd asked
let's see let's let's check out this
first I'm just I'm really curious about
it I want to see what's going on to move
this over a bit so we can see okay so
here's our our Colin
okay so something's going on I guess
inside there is no difference to this
you know container this column class
that should be separating these properly
I guess we do have this added
see what it what it looks like
okay so definitely think the issue is
with this div this is the only thing
that's really changing I mean other
other than the the color of this border
underneath let's see
okay
all right so nothing so far just kind of
messing around in in dev tools trying to
change the display value and things
position I guess may yeah certainly
if we change the position to absolute
this would work right so
I'm CEO this okay that's really tight
that's not a way
although actually if you made it tight
like that I don't mind that
okay so potentially if we changed it
from position relative to position
absolute set the value for bottom to 15
actually let's get rid of that and then
we can just set this value for the
bottom to eight negative eight pixels
and I think that works there's a little
bit of space here it should work as long
as this doesn't bleed over on a second
line which would just have to test and
see if that would would happen thinking
would probably only happen on a smaller
screen so we could do this in a media
query that way it'll behave normally on
a small screen
let's try that we'll try would I just
done here and we'll try to apply it to
everything and just kind of click around
and mess with it on different screen
sizes and see if it works I'm okay with
this right now I know the spacing is a
little bit tight but you know hopefully
you know people won't even see this that
often right they'll type things
correctly and in fact I think this looks
fine and if I hadn't have first seen it
with more spacing in between here I
probably wouldn't really think that much
about it all right my timer did go off
so I'm gonna set my five-minute timer
now go back to live chat answer any
questions you have and see what what
your opinions are on what we've been
doing so far
all right have some people kind of
shouting out where they're from
so from South Africa Africa Ukraine
Ghana awesome welcome so awesome
everyone's watching from all over the
place okay who's this no Peter's saying
expend a little more to the div element
it's more suitable to your screen I'm
not sure what I was looking at when you
said that if I had to guess I'm thinking
maybe you were talking about the
homepage cards maybe you make them a
little bit bigger anyway no beer let me
know would you or when you were thinking
because that was about yeah that was a
while ago for that comment so I I had
scrolled back up to the top of the live
chat and I'm working my way down Frank
asked how do you move that window from
side to side is it a Mac yes it's
because I'm on a Mac so I can you know
have multiple so I've like multiple
desktops right and I can switch between
them
so for each I'm running three screens
right now so you only see one of my
screens but for each screen I have
multiple desktops and can switch between
them so it's really useful especially if
you're consistent and then you kind of
memorize where everything's at and I can
flip between things pretty quickly and
it's all just hand gestures so if I use
three fingers and I swipe then it it
goes and goes between them so it took a
little while to get used to but now it's
definitely more efficient to do things
that way Raina's says congrats on
working on your nano degree Thanks
yeah hopefully I get the nanodegree to
be honest with you this the first
project was okay
I did I did decent job on it you know I
I passed the second project now is
having to do with redux and I've never
used redux before so that's been a lot
more difficult for me the first project
was just react react the router stuff
that you know we're using on this
project so it was a lot easier but I'm
struggling a bit with this one so I need
to really I'm actually considering
taking a day off of work to work on my
project hopefully I won't I won't have
to do that but I'll be spending a lot of
time probably Saturday probably most of
the day Saturday this week working on it
okay cool so Umberto says in regard to
that this you know flipping between the
desktops that you can actually do it on
Windows 10 I was not aware of that I
haven't I have a few computers running
Windows 10 at home and but I haven't
really done much with them for a long
time so I have to try that cool thanks
for mentioning that Umberto
okay here's a good so CF coder 2 says I
would encourage you to include a left
edge color bar you can perhaps code
color code each category of your site so
when we're talking about I'll show you
on this this one so I don't mess up I'm
doing here dev tools so like putting a
color bar here we could have different
colors for each each section I don't
have to think about that because we do
have a few other colors in the color
palette that we haven't even used it all
yet I'll think about that
nobody says nice-looking header Thanks
thank you appreciate it and Frank also
says pretty hot header thank you
cf coder says is there a reason not to
use a class on the h2 tag no not I mean
we could definitely use a class on the
h2 tag to do what we're doing initially
I thought well if I'm just gonna do it
for this page I'm gonna do the inline
Styles and I could always change it to a
class if I end up doing it a lot I ended
up doing it a few times so might not be
a bad idea to just add a class to that
to that age tag so yeah maybe we'll add
a class on there I'm trying to think of
what I would I mean really I could add a
class called no bottom margin and then
that that's really all we're doing so it
could be a utility class I almost hate
to add a class just for that because
it's it's only saving a few characters
from actually doing the inline style so
often I think now that I think about it
I don't even I don't know if it would be
worth it if I added some more to that
class it might be worth it but I don't
know I know there's a lot of different
ideas about how to do CSS how to
organize classes and things like that so
I don't really want to get into all
those differences right now as you can
see there's not set sorry to say but
there's not that much logic to what's
going on with my sass files right now so
they've been kind of like an
afterthought and just throwing in some
Styles here and there where I need them
I haven't really taken a good approach
to organizing it yet
let's see alright my timers up so let me
just I'm actually really close to the
bottom of the live shot let me just take
a few more I did go over a little bit on
my first 25 minutes so let me just get
to the bottom here this live chat since
there's not much left let's see no beer
says I'm curious about your shared story
page how do you in that in in the input
area when input is focused it exactly
works like YouTube live chat or Gmail
login page how do you do it can you
explain okay yeah for sure I'll go over
that I'll go over that in a second
actually whenever we get back to this
because that is kind of a cool a cool
way to do it Frank also said can I use
some of this logic and logic in my
project yeah for sure you use any you
know whatever stuff in the in the code
or you know whatever you want and if you
use it in a project I'd love to see your
project so if it's if it's available on
github or somewhere let me know like
send me either let me know in the live
chat or if you don't want everybody to
see it you can just send me a direct
message on Twitter or something like
that but I really do I'd like to see if
if you are using some of the stuff from
the live streams in your own projects
that I think it's really cool to see
what you all do you know kind of based
on what we've done here and how you
improve it and do different things with
it that I usually never even thought of
doing okay I'm actually I'm gonna go
back here now and just explain a little
bit this so this kind of no beer I'm
assuming that you're talking about just
this kind of effect here that when we
click it you know we get that that line
underneath so this is
just it's a material design kind of
thing that you'll see commonly so that's
why you know you see it on you know
Google things basically this is really
easy to do and react because it's built
into material UI so if you use the
material UI components this is going to
happen for you automatically it also
happens with materialized CSS so if
you're not working with react you can
still get this effect if you use
materialized as your your CSS framework
but you can also do something similar
with just regular CSS so really you you
could do a CSS only version of this too
if you wanted but you know all that's
happening here is you're changing the
position and the size of this of this
text here and then you're adding in some
color and a size to this border right so
just knowing that alone won't give you
the exact effect because if you can see
it's actually more like a second border
expanding here so if you wanted that
effect of it expanding you'd have to do
a little bit more and actually have an
entirely different you know span or div
there that was going to grow in size so
but you could certainly do that and I
think I may have implemented some form
of this in CSS and a previous project I
can't remember what project it was right
now I think though I didn't have the
complete effect I think what I did was I
just changed you know this border here
so it didn't kind of grow out but
everything else works the same so anyway
hopefully that was explained a little
bit of what was going on there but yeah
you can easiest way to do it is use the
framework either material UI if you're
using react or materialized CSS if you
use
thing else or you can do it on your own
just probably the easiest way is just
check out how it's done on a Google site
just to get your values for your CSS so
you know font size and the amount that
this moves you know things like that the
the width of the bottom border here and
the change in width so get those values
from some site that's using something
like this
and then you can work it in you know
whatever way you like to do it into your
CSS or even use some JavaScript to help
you with the effects you know depending
on what you're comfortable with and it's
not really it's not super hard to do I
when I had done this just in some CSS I
remember being somewhat surprised that
how how easy it was to get you know
something really similar to this going
okay so let me start my time up again I
wanted to get through everything in the
live chat but I'm I'm not I'll have to
wait till the next break to get get
through more of it so I will come back
to that same spot in the live chat so
right around for me for my timestamp
it's 234 p.m. so it's Eastern time okay
let's start this up again and let's try
to apply what we've done here
so basically all we changed for this
element is we've set the position to
absolute and we've put the bottom value
as negative 8 pixels so now let's figure
out how to target this it doesn't look
like there's hmm so there's no class no
ID we can target
let's see
let me check so we are using form Z
react and in particular we are using the
material the material UI version of this
which I think there's a link to form Z
material UI so if there's a way to
target that div specifically I'd like to
do that otherwise I think we can do it
with I think we can do it another way
let's see that I pass
who
and I don't see not really much for
documentation for this
all right well let's
alright let's just try to target this
then with some CSS so if we go let's
look at what's going on here I think I
have this open already that's a test
service request test maybe I don't have
it open anyone there we go alright so
let's check this out
these are calm classes
let's see if we can add a class name
okay cool so we have our class now on
this container div and we know
the last
then we have all righty Serena's house
okay let's try this where's our styles
are
I'm just gonna put it in the home styles
because we are using forms on more than
one page so let's do this that's what we
named it right rooms the input and let's
see I think if I do div can I do last
that's the will that work
let's try I always mess up when I try to
do these kind of pseudo selector things
but it's worth a shot
we're gonna have to use important to
override those inline Styles normally
would not be using important but not
really not really a decent option to do
it other than that and would be a bottom
negative eight pixels alright so let's
see if this works
oh ho nice okay so we got some stuff
going on here
oh do we not put important that's
important
important so this should work now yeah
it works all right let's make sure it
actually applied to some other things
awesome great
let's see project description I think
this needs to be
to be not having I guess we didn't have
any type of validation on these other
ones actually this one is numeric right
now there we go okay
interesting
this is this shouldn't have done
anything
Yeah right I should have done anything
okay let's add in that I was just I was
just checking it out because it should
not have it shouldn't have done anything
with the styles but this seemed like
this was a lot tighter up to the bottom
of here than it normally would have been
so for a second I thought that some of
our Styles did somehow get applied but
we didn't put the class on any of the
multiline inputs yet so let's add this
class name in to our multi line fields
as well and like yes I guess we can add
it in here let's see
this added in here as well and we don't
have to worry about the checkboxes and
now let's awesome great ok so we have
you know we have these working great
great alright so
let's see
I guess the next thing we're going these
checkboxes then I know what you think I
mean check the live chat really quickly
just to see if anyone has has anything
to say like maybe I did something really
silly and I didn't realize it
okay so it looks like CF code or 2 s is
the input dropping location below the
label from the form input as you type
into the input something you styled or
did that come with form Z
that is formzee so well yes I mean this
this effect here is not actually just
forms this is material UI but you know
this here is its with form Z I'm pretty
sure it is I could double check maybe
this does come with material UI in forms
he just gives you some extra ways to
format this and validate I'm not 100%
sure on that but so you might want to
check out the material UI documentation
on text inputs to see if they have this
validation field built-in but this for
sure is built in a material UI Rohan
good good look so Roman says it is it
just me or the underlines gone you're
right the underlines are gone what the
heck
all right so something happened and we
don't have underlines let's see what
happened
water bottle
all right let me take let's take this
class name off of something here see if
that brings him back
okay yeah so definitely something we did
took this took those boarders off the
bottom so let's see what we did
it says no that's not what has the
border
with
part of this has the border
this is it okay so this is where the
borders coming from so let's see what
it's the one on these
that's what okay I thought about this
and I didn't realize I didn't realize
that these that this div contained the
borders so they're actually a chars
right with with borders okay
so what we want to do then is
let's put it back in here just take this
out
we should still have borders see
I see now
okay all right I see now so this won't
work
yeah if this won't work so what's
happening is the div that I was trying
to target as the last if they're only
appears if there's an error and then
it's not even in the Dom if there's not
an error so then it switches and this
becomes the last day of where the border
is so we need to figure out some other
way to target this div
all right let me see I I haven't I this
is gonna be the not a great way to do
this but I think it's gonna be how we
have to do it so we have to so let's
just do EQ 2 for our target here so
let's give how's this work I can't
remember how you do this and CSS I'll
have to look it up oh no is it not CSS
there's it
I'll EQ is the jQuery way to do it all
right we could do
let's let's do what was that - I'm
Shawna remember if it's zero indexed or
not I don't think it is okay all right
let's try it try this
let's put this in this world
how can we do
somehow this is
Oh ro alright I just looked over the
live chat and see you've seen what you
type in there everyone it's not gonna
work let's see if this works for this
okay so it's working for these it's not
but for the multi-line inputs it's not
working so let's we're gonna have to do
something different for the multi-line
so I'm guessing that this has
okay so this the second div for these
inputs has the border
I mean it's gonna be a little bit more
complicated and I want it to be but I
think
and we should only need to customize it
one more time
Farzin multi-line
alright let's see see what that does
okay that works Wow all right
okay
all right so that looks like it is
working now we have our underlines okay
all right so this is what we ended up
needing we needed two different classes
so that's okay
it looks like oops we need to change
this is a multi line for our upload the
the input that we're putting our file
names into is multi-line as well so
let's switch that okay great I want to
check how much time I have left and this
old man
two minutes okay I do want to at least
check to see what's going on with this
why we're getting such a large amount of
space between here
interesting okay
we change this
all right so for this I'm wondering if
we couldn't do the similar thing
changing it to absolute position mmm the
only thing I'm I guess I could just
position out there yeah I think we could
probably do the same thing with absolute
position and then avoid having that gap
so let's go with
oh no it's up wait all right we would
need to switch
there we go
okay so this is going to be probably not
going to finish this in the stream but
this is I think going to be the solution
that will work so we've changed the
positioning of the image itself to use
absolute instead of relative position
and then we just need to adjust the top
and the right attributes here to get it
positioned over to where it was before
but the key is you notice when we first
did this and we made a position absolute
when we took off that top value it went
way up here right so what we had to do
is make give the containing give the
position of relative then it would be
absolute based on that container div so
that's kind of CSS has I don't know it
seems like some weird things when it
comes to positioning and that and
correct me if I'm wrong but from what I
remember from the last time I dealt with
this the absolute you put position
absolute on something it's absolute as
related to the nearest parent div that
it has a position of relative if there's
no parent divs that have a position
relative then it's just based on
basically the entire window right so
that's why I shot right up here and
that's why it went back down whenever I
took this div and I put position
relative on it right so if you have
something happen like that if you if you
can without messing things up at a
position relative to the container div
then that should make it a lot easier to
position things like that so I think
this should be this should solve it I
definitely want to test it out to make
sure but I haven't even tossed any other
problems but that should be it and then
you know we'll have a much much nicer
spacing between that
okay so been streaming for I did two I
only did two Pomodoro sessions but I
think I went over on both of them and I
went over talking so on my break so
we're actually almost an
and a half into the stream at this point
so I'm going to go to the live chat now
and answer some questions so if you
can't stick around for the question and
answer session totally understand that
the coding portion of this is done so
thank you so much for watching if you
can't stick around and you have
questions please put them in the live
chat right now even if you don't have a
question it will be nice if you could
help answer some of the questions in the
live chat I'm certainly not an expert at
at everything I may not be an expert at
anything but so it definitely helps if
more people were in the live chat and
helping to contribute to give you know
some really good answers to anyone
that's in here so don't worry if you're
a beginner you know any questions are
fine don't don't be afraid nobody's
going to laugh at you or say anything
mean to you for if you ask a question
that they think is basic or something
like that I guess if someone is mean to
somebody about the questions they ask in
here then I'm not gonna be happy about
it so let me scroll up to where I was
and keep going from from that point
okay so Rohan says the last two
paragraphs in the submit suggested story
forum should actually be shown after
someone submits the story so let me
check that out again look into each tip
in determine my my fila website yeah I
guess it would make sense I'm just
wondering like would that flow be weird
if there's a forum just right in the
middle of these paragraphs I guess I
could just I just do it and see what it
looks like but that I mean I would move
the forum up a little bit more well
maybe I'll have to check that out at
some point and just and see how it looks
if it doesn't if it doesn't look weird
to have that form right there then I'm
okay with that
actually I mean if on a different site
what I would probably end up doing is is
having this in some sort of banner so
like a full width like color section
here and then put that in the middle and
then it would kind of stand out I think
and not look but with the way this site
is I'm not I'm not sure that it would
look right we're not doing anything else
like that on the whole site yeah I'll
have to think about that anyway thanks
for the suggestion I actually haven't I
don't even remember the last time I read
what what this text actually said it's
probably been like a year and a half
since I've read this stuff so you
probably helped to read it and see if it
even makes sense where I'm putting it
okay Alexander says Jessie you can
resize your page to a certain device in
dev tools it's the second top left icon
yeah definitely thanks for bringing that
up so I I do use that sometimes so talk
about this this dev tools icon here
which brings this up so you can do like
right now it's iPhone 4 I had to use
this before I found what I use so this
is good I use this but what I started to
use that I think I like even better I
mean that this is useful and really
quick to do but if I have time to do
more I like to for since I'm on a Mac
for iPhone devices and iPads I actually
use the simulator in Ex tools and that
gives me a more accurate representation
of what it would be like on a real
iPhone and then well obviously I have an
Android phone so I test on the Android I
have a pixel so I can test on there but
then also we have a browser stack
account that I can go on browser stack
and test on on different devices as well
so I know browser stack is you know cost
money but if you if you can get your
employer to pay for it it's really
useful or you know if you have if you
have your own freelance business or
agency or something like I would I I've
found it to be very useful and
definitely way less expensive than
buying all those devices for testing
yourself but thank you thanks Alexander
that's definitely like such a useful
feature in dev tools and Alexander also
is a question it says is it better to
use inline styles on a component or to
write CSS in a different file using
classes and all that goodies of
pre-processors yeah so I don't I don't
necessarily have a rule that I stick to
all the time but it would depend on what
I want to do in the situation right so
if it's just kind of what I was saying
before like
if I need to make a change on something
that I don't think I'll use often or you
know anywhere else within the site I
just use inline Styles it's fast it's
easy for someone to come in and look at
that component and know exactly what
it's gonna look like because they can
see the style right there if I have to
put a lot of styles I'd rather do it in
a separate sheet right because I don't
want all those inline Styles cluttering
up that component if I have a style that
I want to be repeated in lots of places
throughout the site I put it in a
separate CSS or sass file if there's
something that I'm doing that I want to
do that would be beneficial to use the
you know preprocessor for like sass like
mix-ins or variables or something like
that then I'll do it in the sass file if
I need to use a hover effect or a media
query
I'm obviously can't do that inline so
I'm going to do that in a CSS file so it
kind of you know the answer is it
basically coming just depends on your
situation but for sure like it's just
really fast especially if I'm testing
things out I'm like I'm not sure if I
really want to keep it like that I'm
just testing styles it's usually faster
just to do something inline really quick
especially if you don't already have a
CSS file
you know linked up to that component you
know a lot of times I just put it in
there a third option is to do something
like CSS and j/s or there's a there's a
lot of different ways right now to put
CSS in the component and it's not inline
but you can put it either like in the
top like as a constant or something and
then you bring it in
to the component or you can it just
depends on what you're using so there
there are other ways than just the kind
of the two either in line or in a
separate file there's kind of a hybrid
method of having styles that you can
write out like normal styles you do in
CSS but they're actually included within
your component so in my last project
I got into some of that and then in
future projects I'll probably try some
different methods out as well because
I'm really interested in trying the
different ones out and seeing what's the
best one so my knowledge at least from
what I've read in videos I've watched
there's not really like one standard
that's emerged is the best way to do it
there's still a lot of different things
being used so which is kind of cool I'm
sure at some point once things you know
kind of mature with react there'll be
something that is kind of accepted that
most people use but for now I think it's
it's kind of wide open as to what you
know to use what's best for your use
case for your situation and and just
your preferences anyway that was kind of
a long answer but hopefully it was
helpful
okay CF kotor - actually asks a similar
thing I noticed CF kotor 2 says I
noticed you use a lot of inline styling
is there a reason for not using more
class definitions to reuse styling so I
basically my answer the last question
probably answered that because that's
that's kind of my my philosophy on
inline vs styling versus using classes
and things like that so hopefully I
answered that if not if I didn't answer
that you can you know ask ask me to
follow up on that and be more specific I
guess
okay so no beer actually had a response
to Alexander's question about the inline
styles versus you know putting in style
sheets so no bears opinion is that
styling you know directly in the
component is is better than having it in
line because then your component or your
HTML depending on what you're using
isn't is more clean right so yeah and
I'm definitely so I would agree with
that right so I think as I said before
I'm not opposed to using inline styles
in certain situations as long as it's a
you know just one style or maybe two
styles right but I don't want to get it
cluttered you know I want everything to
seem clean within the component as well
so I'm not entirely against it but
definitely I definitely agree with that
okay CF kotor - says your site looks
great thank you I appreciate that but
also some suggestion you can enhance
your site even more by adding a
background image semi-transparent or
left edge more bold image that shrinks
and with as device shrinks yeah I'll
think about that
I actually I was thinking about that a
bit when we were looking at the the
homepage so yesterday we had did some
stuff to the homepage but I mean right
now especially I mean this probably
isn't a common trying to find a more
common screen with but it's not as bad
kind of with a more common with but if
you get a large screen there there's
just so much space so I kind of thought
about doing some sort of background
image or something but I'm not 100% sure
about it yeah I'm not I'm not sure about
it I'm kind of still thinking about it I
almost I didn't want to go with that
because so I'm recreating in react
something that already exists as kind of
a jQuery single page application and so
I'm trying to mimic the how that looks
so that the transition will be as easy
as possible for the users so I didn't
really want to add too much but I'm
definitely going to think about that
because I this does just look a little
bit you know - I think yeah we think we
talked about this yesterday is it just
looks stark yes I'll think about that
thank you for the suggestion
okay at some point Alexander capita said
use an ID and then put some question
marks oh sorry I didn't get to that
earlier I'm not sure was that when we
were I think that was when I was trying
to to get the get the div like for the
service request form for that error
message so I mean I wanted to use a
class instead of an ID because it was
going to be applied to multiple elements
right because we were iterating over the
data and putting in multiple elements so
unless I'm unless I'm mistaken about
what the what you were talking about
with the ID I think a class would have
been more appropriate there but maybe
I'm misunderstanding
okay cool so CF code or to actually put
a a link to a site - that's kind of an
example of the image so let's see I'm
checking out on my other screen here
okay cool I'll bring this over on my
screen to C so C F code or two was
saying like to put kind of an image like
in the background so yes I could see
that yeah yeah I think about the one
that we use a lot of things like this
for our external sites that are more
like marketing site usually focus that
trying to get students interested in the
university I haven't really done a lot
with this kind of thing for internal
sites because I kind of I just keep them
like really like more more focused on
you know here's what you need to do so
they're not nearly as kind of flashy but
okay yeah I'll think about it thanks for
the for the example
all right click on the shows page to see
if cute coder says click on the shows
page
okay
so are you thinking then maybe each
section would have you know different
things like this different color yeah I
really like this I mean I agree normally
so here's what I'm kind of what I'm kind
of torn between right so like normally I
would be more flashy with with my site
if he like said if this was an external
site if the audience was external but
whenever we bring this up so like
initially when I was designing this I
was having a lot of meetings with people
in my department one of the things that
they really liked and wanted was the
fact that immediately users see all the
options and only the options and there's
not a lot of scrolling involved
basically the idea was this needs to be
very user friendly and appeal to a lot
of people the university that are older
and really don't they don't use
computers that much and there's actually
a certain percentage of people the
university that are very against using
computers for a lot of things so the
idea was basically like don't clutter
don't do anything like just give them
and initially we only actually had six
options here so we didn't even have as I
added these three for this one but the
current version of it only has six so
it's really like immediately here are
the things you can do and that's it so
I'm a little bit hesitant to the kind of
change that
so I agree that it would look nicer if
we did something else more flashy but
I'm kind of like it's almost like think
of this as very like a utilitarian like
a dashboard right if you go to like
Google Analytics dashboard or something
they don't have a lot of images and
flashy things like they would have maybe
if you go to like the Google store right
where they're trying to sell you
something Google Analytics like you're
going there because you want this data
and you want to see your options right
so this is kind of what what we're going
for here is like there's certain
information that people need to go here
we don't need to sell them on anything
this is more of just a resource so
anyway that's just kind of like a
background as to what we're going for
here and maybe kind of the reasoning for
doing this so I am still gonna think
about this and how I can incorporate it
but I'm I mean at least like you could
see kind of my reasoning as to why I'm
more hesitant to do it like that
the other reason to that I'm a little
bit hesitant about images is once you
get into that then you have to I have to
actually think about what images I want
in there and select the images and
handle you know handle everything that
goes in with images because if I did
that I'd certainly want to have multiple
image sizes to do you know responsive
images and things like that so it does
add a little bit more complexity to a
project that you know really should be
wrapping up and should go live probably
next week it's not entirely up to me I
need to get feedback from other people
but assuming that I would get prompt
feedback you know this needs this should
go live soon anyway I think it's a good
debate I kind of would want to hear what
everyone else thinks about that yeah
because like I said I haven't really I
haven't really tried anything like that
for this but yeah I don't know let me
know what you all think I can't
guarantee that I'll be able to go with
you know your suggestions in that area
even if I agree with it you know I still
kind of have to since that would be a
significant change to the look of this I
still you know it would have to be
approved by people higher up in my
department as well but I guess I'm open
I'm open to the idea
okay Rohan says positioning and CSS is a
nightmare
yeah sure it's uh yeah sometimes it can
definitely be it can be tricky
let's see oh cool Alexander says thank
you Jesse you're the man you're welcome
CF kotor 2 says Jesse what's your
contact info I'd like to chat offline
later yeah my I have some of my info in
the description so like Instagram
Twitter if you go to my youtube channel
which I think I have links as well in
the description if not it's just I think
I for sure I have a link in my Twitter a
description I also have linked up some
of my other social media so if you want
to get a hold of me through through
whatever social media channel you like
best that's cool just you know send me a
message
Oh John Henson says if you use a
background image you would need to
prefetch and store it in cash
not sure how create react app uses
serviceworkers to make that efficient
yeah actually I'm not sure either I
haven't done a lot with with images and
create react app I say did do the first
project I did for the nanodegree had
images as well maybe I'll have to take a
look at that and see how how about was
done but that's a good point I hadn't
really thought of that
uh-huh okay John Hanson says in regard
to the images I guess says I get older
we usually need simple straightforward
mike says I bet I am the best coder in
here that's entirely possible Mike I've
never really seen your coat or your work
but you know that's it's definitely
fault I don't think it would take that
much to be a better coder than I am so
I'm not gonna argue with you there but
we do have some really knowledgeable
people in here in the chat so definitely
have some competition for best coder
oh cool all right so CF coder to found
the my Twitter and sent me some some
tweets they're so awesome well take a
look at those and get back to you soon
as I can
mike is saying I might give even give
you some lessons sometimes you just have
to go if your passion yeah Mike
certainly if you ever have any advice
and you want to put it in the live chat
it's definitely appreciated okay
Rolo I mentioned earlier that CSS
positioning can be tricky sometimes and
John Hanson says positioning is a charm
with CSS grid all browsers will be on
board except internet explorer by
January 2018
that's awesome off to check into that I
haven't really done much at all with CSS
grid so if it's going to be supported
with browsers then that's that's great
all right cool Steve asks how much would
it cost to have this site developed hmm
I don't know I haven't really thought
about how much I would charge for for
this site I guess I could give you like
a ballpark figure I suppose
I don't know maybe like if I were going
to do something like this for a client
also like including like server setup
and everything like that
SSL like I don't know maybe probably the
lowest I would go is I don't know it's
tough to say on the spot but maybe like
I don't know somewhere between 5,000 and
15,000 I know that's a big range but I
have to really think about it more it's
hard to say though because this is not
really a normal site like so many
decisions were already made ahead of
time the content was already there so
things were already set up like some of
the accounts were set up like the
SendGrid api stuff so I don't know so I
guess this project seems somewhat easier
than it would have been if I was
starting from scratch and had to make a
lot of these decisions that were already
made so that's why I have such a big
range cuz I'm not I'm not exactly sure
what this would be like let's see
so anyway I don't know I'd be good to
see what you all think that you would
charge for something like this or that
you would pay for something like this
it's always interesting to see like
pricing opinions on pricing and also I'm
not sure what it's like for different
areas of the world so like right now I'm
in the United States so in other
countries or even other areas in the
United States I guess pricing could
could be a lot you know different
chuna instances don't don't web
developers make around $5 an hour when
they charge $30 an hour are you are you
saying that because projects in the
community John I'm so what's what's up
with that they comment are you saying
that because projects end up always
taking longer or what if it's hourly I
guess it shouldn't matter right
okay all right I've gotten to the bottom
of the live chat so wow we've been going
for almost two hours now so it's
definitely definitely about that time to
wrap things up I really appreciate
everything oh we had a foreigner okay so
DP solution says I think he didn't make
preparation he is like a child speak for
a while and then silent so I'm assuming
this talking about me and you're you are
right I I make no preparations for these
videos so yeah and in terms of the
speaking and in being silent like yeah
that most of the time that's because I'm
trying to read something what's going on
the live chat so anyway yeah that's
entirely right yeah these these streams
are not I don't prepare for these the
the point of these streams are to show
what it's like for me as a front-end
developer to do my day-to-day work so I
purposely want to keep in any mistakes I
make I don't want it to be scripted or
rehearsed because that wouldn't be an
accurate representation of what I do so
obviously I don't narrate what I'm doing
doing my normal job but I I do want us
to be somewhat helpful as well
so that's why I try to narrate things
but so that's why you know coming in if
you know this is definitely not the
place for a thorough tutorial and it's
certainly not efficient
you know since right we're doing this on
the fly I make a lot of mistakes I stop
for questions I do things so you know
definitely a shorter more concise
tutorial would be better if you don't
have a lot of time but like I said this
is not the point of this is not really
like tutorial based it's more of I just
had the idea that it might be good
instead of saying pre rehearse
videos which are awesome just to see
somebody mess up sometimes and but still
work through it and still produce you
know produce something so yeah so anyway
I try to I don't always remember to
explain that when I do the streams but I
try to do it you know when I remember
because I imagine it could be somewhat
confusing for new people watching to see
like hey what the heck is this guy doing
like he doesn't know what he's doing
he's messing up so anyway that was I
just kind of thought like I know when I
started out at the beginning it was I
loved watching the YouTube videos or
these people that were amazing but it
did somewhat make me feel like wow these
people were like way better than me and
they were better than me legitimately
but it gives kind of a false impression
that like I was making way more mistakes
than I should when in reality I think at
least for me I make mistakes right I I
produce websites that work that fulfill
you know the requirements of my clients
of where I work so I am employed
full-time as a front-end developer so I
mean I'm I'm getting work done and I'm
producing work that I'm proud of but I
still make a lot of mistakes and I have
to learn as I'm going so I just kind of
wanted people to see like that and kind
of see how I need to struggle through
things and I was kind of hoping it would
give new people some hope that like you
know that everybody's just kind of
struggling and learning as they go so
anyway that was that was kind of purpose
so hopefully that kind of explains why
it does you know it does really seem
like this is just kind of me winging it
sometimes because that's that's the
point
[Music]
so I didn't get a few more messages
while I was while I was talking so let
me just read through these
make sure there's no questions that I
need to answer before I end things
okay bill well says thanks for all the
effort Jessie oh you're welcome today I
have one question should I just watch
your videos or would it be useful if I
code alongside you two I've never really
thought about coding alongside I would
say it definitely depends on what you
want to get out of the videos and what
type of learner you are some people do
really well with just watching other
people have the ability to do multiple
things and still pick things up so if
you know like that that hands-on type of
thing is better for you then go ahead I
know there are some people that do other
work and just kind of listen to me in
the background and then occasionally
like they'll they'll come over and
contribute in the live chat so I guess I
don't really have that I don't really
think there's like one way that's best
to watch these these videos you know
I've found you know people do it
differently some people don't even watch
the live streams often and they watch
the recording on like two times speed
and that's better for them so sorry I
can't really give you a definite answer
on that just some ideas for how other
people have told me that they do it
okay Rohan says I personally have the
stream going on in the background while
I browse through the interwebs projects
here - targeted to practice alongside
yeah for sure that's that's a good point
yeah sometimes it might be difficult to
go alongside to code alongside also
because I work on this in between
streams it might sometimes be hard to
catch up I do try to keep the github
repo as up-to-date as possible so
potentially you could pull in all the
changes at the beginning of each show
and be right right there so it would be
possible I think to code alongside but
for me I would probably have trouble
doing it personally
but you know that that might just be my
you know kind of my style of how I
learned enable am able to do things but
it might work well for you I don't know
okay now I'm for real this time to the
bottom of the live chat I've read
through everything I think I think I've
gotten to all the all the questions if I
miss your question I'm sorry about that
you can ask it again in another live
chat or put in the comment to the videos
send me a message on social media
somewhere and I'll try to get to it when
I can I will I'm gonna try to stream
tomorrow my schedule tomorrow is really
filled up I have meetings in the morning
I have a doctor's appointment in the
afternoon it's going to be tough to find
a time to get into stream but if I am
going to stream tomorrow I'll schedule
the stream sometime tomorrow morning
I'll post on Twitter when I'm gonna
stream so if you don't see anything on
Twitter or any notifications come up for
from the free coke and YouTube channel
then I'm probably you know not gonna be
able to stream it I really just am not
sure how long my appointments gonna take
so I don't know whether I'll have time
to to come back and stream after that I
had hoped to be able to stream in the
morning tomorrow but then I am now
required to go to a very long meeting
tomorrow that I didn't think I'd have to
go to so and I just found out about that
yesterday yeah so I think in case I
don't get to stream tomorrow I have a
wonderful weekend everyone should be
back same time on Monday in any case no
matter what happens tomorrow thank you
so much for for watching for
contributing in the live chat you know
for all your your your help and your
opinions going through this I it really
helps it makes the end product just so
much better so so I guess in until until
tomorrow or maybe Monday have a have a
great day